the next speaker is my great pleasure to
introduce
professor kevin leighton brown uh
kevin it it's fair to say is
the originator of this field
unless you know you want to correct me
on that kevin on the use of machine
learning in the context of solvers
i'm sure moshe will uh will send some
references in the chat to correct you on
that
no i think i i think on this one i agree
with uh
with vijay
and uh so kevin is a professor of
computer science at ubc
got his phd at stanford and he has won
many awards for his research uh
including an
anserk ewr stacy memorial
fellowship and uh several other awards
uh so without further ado uh kevin the
floor is yours and you may share your
screen and
start the talk thank you
thanks you think i'd be faster sharing
my screen by now after a year in
pandemic
um uh yeah i guess i i made the crack
about uh
moshe sharing the references because the
truth is this field goes back
a long time in uh particularly into
systems and you know
all kinds of you know different places
that kind of ml for solvers kind of
cropped up
um before they kind of got unified into
this uh
this community that we have today but uh
but i think it's really exciting that
we're at the point where we have simon's
workshops dedicated to this topic
i think this is a really exciting thing
um
i'm going to speak about something
a little bit less practical than we've
heard from the other speakers today
i'm going to talk about using machine
learning to directly predict the
uh the result that we would get from a
combinatorial solver
um given the the topic of the the
the broader simon's semester i'm going
to look at
propositional satisfiability and i'm
going to survive a whole range of
different work
that my group has done over the years um
culminating in some work on
end-to-end learning i'm using deep
learning to to predict propositional
satisfiability directly from raw inputs
to get so i'm going to be throughout
speaking about uniform random threesat
at the phase transition
not because these are the the most
important sad problems
practically to study that it's obviously
a bit of a toy problem
but it's a very clean well-studied
problem
that is sort of the the fruit fly of sat
research
it's empirically hard a lot of people
have looked at it and
we have maybe the best theory about it
so um it's kind of
you know conventional wisdom that at
this causes to variables ratio of 4.26
um uniform random three-sat problems are
have a 50 chance of being satisfiable
which is true
and they're empirically hard which is
sort of almost true
here's um if we look at uh
actual empirical performance uh instance
by instance
on a log scale at the phase transition
point
you see that in fact um you know this is
where this average hardness spikes
but you also see that uh there's
a lot more variation than you might have
expected there's still real really easy
instances at this point as well
so um some co-authors and i got
interested in the
sort of somewhat ridiculous question of
saying could we use machine learning
to to try to predict you know which um
which kind of instance we've got in hand
if we were at this phase transition
point if we had some well-defined set of
instances and we wanted to
take some new instance from this set and
try to determine
is it going to be hard or easy to solve
and so we uh in a whole string of work
i'll just have some
citations at the bottom here but a whole
string of work culminating in a
cacm paper in 2014
we said let's try to find some instance
features of this
sat instance that we could compute in
polynomial time that would give us a
handle
on its combinatorial structure that we
could then use in a model to try to
predict whether the instance is
is hard or easy so the most obvious
thing you might think of if you've taken
a kind of undergrad
algorithms class is the size of the
problem so how many clauses does it have
how many variables does it have
what's the clauses to variables ratio uh
of course these will all be constant if
i was looking at the the uh
phase transition point then i can look
at other things like
syntactic properties and for example
what's the ratio of positive to negative
uh clauses uh in the uh
in the formula i can then build various
constraint graphs and say
such as the the factor graph the clause
clause graph or the variable clause
graph
i could ask things like uh what are the
average degree
statistics in the graph or what are path
lengths in the graph or how clustered
are the graphs
i can use the search space size estimate
due to don knuth where you
um you look at the you make some random
probes
in a sort of dpl space and say what's
the
average depth in the tree and that's a
an estimate of the log number of nodes
in the tree
i can do look at the cumulative number
of unit props that i would get
at different depths using a given
heuristic like the sad c heuristic
and say how amenable to this heuristic
does the
formula appear to be i can take local
search algorithms even if
the algorithm that ultimately i'm
interested in is not a local search
algorithm
and i can say using some bounded amount
of time
what happens when i run the local search
heuristic do i
um do i find that i um
quickly reach a plateau or does it
improve a lot or
how much variation do i get in the kinds
of um
trajectories that i see in this sort of
bounded local search unrollings
um across different random restarts of
the local search
heuristic and finally i can take a
linear programming relaxation of the
problem
um and and then i can look at the slack
vector of this
linear program the uh how far from
integral
the the variables in linear programming
relaxation are
and and um take like a norm of that
vector or
a coefficient of variation of that
vector and
get a sense of how close it is to
integral so so we built all kinds of
features like this you know
this wasn't meant to be comprehensive
and it certainly wasn't meant to be
formal
but it gives you a sense of the kinds of
things you could dream up and
and you could probably dream up more
so um so then we're using um pretty
simple
regression kinds of methods we were able
to
build models that predict
make predictions like this so here i'm
saying on the x-axis
what was the actual run time on a log
scale
of a sat solver like kc and f's and on
the y axis
what do we predict the runtime to be and
you know we would like to exactly nail
this
this diagonal red line and what we got
here was
uh pretty good you know it's always hard
to sort of eyeball a scatter plot and
that could give you numbers which are
also kind of hard to interpret
but you know we're able to do um
reasonably well
in in predicting um unseen problems at
the
phase transition point where the closest
to variables ratio is telling us nothing
so we found this intriguing and we
wanted to dig in
so we started saying what if i tried to
build much smaller models that i could
then interpret
and we did this by i'm using um
forward selection which is a greedy way
of doing variable selection in a
in some kind of model framework so here
we were using quadratic regression um
and so we we iteratively added features
to quadratic regression and
and and found that four variable models
in this case did pretty well
so so here was a good four variable
model and here's how much
it hurt us to lose uh just scaled to
a hundred percent here's how much it
cost us to lose each of these four
variables
and so you see the last one was the
least very valuable and
interpreting this we can see that these
local search um probing features that i
told you about were
important all over the place so every
one of these four
um and quadratic
um features that that we've learned here
includes one of these
local search probing features and
donald knuth's search space size
estimate feature
featured in two of the four and the
variable clause um
graph node heuristic also features in
the last one so
um so this gives us some sense of what's
what's going on in terms of
understanding how these models are able
to make good predictions
um let me shift for a minute to variable
um ratio problems so here we're we're
sampling around the
the phase transition not only at the
phase transition we're able to predict
much better in this point
um and here i'm going to color our
predictions by whether the problems were
satisfiable or unsatisfiable
and you see a kind of interesting trend
here that
the unsatisfiable unsatisfiable instance
are are predicted much more accurately
than the
satisfiable instances uh which might
make sense to you because
in the in the case where an instance is
unsatisfal
unsatisfiable you've got to search the
entire tree
and uh so there's going to be much less
variance
across sort of random noise whereas
the the heuristic that um stops as soon
as it finds a satisfying assignment
um might be more um easily
manipulated by slight variation in the
problem instance and so we might get
more um more variation in runtime so so
we certainly see more variation
anyway in the uh predictions of our
um our models so uh we were intrigued
though by
by the uh the great difference between
the quality of our predictions for
unsatisfiable and satisfiable instances
and this led us to ask whether we could
build much better models if we
imagined that we knew the satisfiability
status of an instance
um of course this means the the clauses
and variables ratio would be unimportant
and indeed it turned out that single
feature models in this case became
sufficient
so when
instances were satisfiable then turns
out those local search probing features
that i told you about before
were all you needed to make good
predictions
and when instances were unsatisfiable
then those search space size estimates
turned out to be sufficient to make good
predictions
so um of course we don't know the
satisfiability status of an issue
an instance if we did we wouldn't
presumably want to run a sat solver in
the first place
um but this is still kind of an
interesting insight maybe into how these
models are working and why these two
families of features turned out to be so
important in our
fixed variable um models that we were
looking at and for
the fixed ratio models we were looking
in the first place so
so then we had a kind of audacious idea
that maybe only machine learning
oriented people could have
we wondered could we build a kind of
hierarchical model that would begin by
predicting satisfiability status
and then it would condition on this
prediction as a feature to combine the
predictions of the sat only and
unsightly models that we had just seen
worked well
let me point out that this would not
necessarily be an easy thing to do
because if we could make these
predictions really accurately we would
do well
but these sat only and unsightly models
do egregiously badly
when they're given the wrong input so
if these predictions ever went wrong our
models
could potentially be terrible and
nevertheless we showed in joint work
with lin shu and holger hoos back at cp
in 2007
that that we could do much better with
this kind of an approach
so uh here's the the same graph i showed
you before on the left
and then a graph on the same data using
this hierarchical hardness model
approach
and you see that we really managed to
reduce the variance substantially
and especially on the especially visible
and the
unsatisfiable instances so
um so let me go back for the rest of the
talk to to fixed ratio i
just had the variable ratio problem so i
could show you this picture which was on
variable ratio
but uh going back to fixed ratio
for the rest of the talk i don't want to
think about predicting runtime anymore
that's really just how we came to this
problem
but i want to instead really think about
this this question of satisfiability
status so
from that work i here's the models that
we had predicted at the time
that we built at the time and here's how
they how they worked so
these models predicted a probability of
sat they didn't just predict
a a kind of discrete class of whether
something was sad or not
and you see that as the model became
less less certain about
the satisfiability status it also became
more wrong so the model was
relatively calibrated in its predictions
and we then went um
again with ling shu and holger huss into
a deeper dive into trying to understand
does it really make sense to think that
we could predict the satisfiability
status
of a phase transition instance
which we we kind of believe to be a hard
distribution of problems
so to try to understand this better we
tried to tie a couple of hands behind
our backs and and
build something um that would persuade
us
more fundamentally that this was even
doable so
we considered phase transition instances
that varied from 100 variables which are
problems that are solvable in
milliseconds
even back in 2012 when we did the work
to 600 variable problems which were
solvable in about a day
back in 2012 and now still take kind of
hours
and um what we wanted to know was
as the problem sizes scaled up would
prediction accuracy fall to random
guessing as problems get bigger
um and if not can we identify some
easily comprehensible model that would
offer theoretical insight into what was
going on
and and this sort of experimental setup
was uh inspired by
conversations with some theorists i
think in part at simon's
um who um wanted to
uh you just didn't believe that that
this was
really going to be possible to do they
thought it might just kind of be a
small size effect and of course because
all of our
experiments are empirical i can't really
ever say that this isn't a small size
effect because
whatever finite size i look at you can
always tell me is small
but but here's the best i can do to try
to argue that this isn't a small size
effect
so what we did is we trained only on
these
millisecond solvable instances the 100
variable instances
um and the reason we didn't go even
smaller is we didn't want
problems that were kind of resolvable in
cash we wanted them to
to involve some amount of search um
so that they would be in some sense
representative of larger instances
we considered only models that use
decision trees within most two decision
nodes
and we turned off all probing features
so probing features are things like
um the local search probing like donald
knuth's search space size estimate
like the um use of the
sad z heuristic to look at unit
propagations all of these kinds of
things that run solvers for a bounded
amount of time
because using bounded amounts of time
isn't going to scale
from one size to another we wanted
instead features that looked at some
kind of structural property of an
instance
that would be well defined from one size
to another so that we would believe that
it would actually
capture something combinatorial about
the instance um
and uh and we wanted to see you know
would it still be the case that
that we could build something that would
do well in larger instances
and to our surprise we we found that it
actually worked really
ridiculously reliably so here is a
simple model that beat random guessing
and it achieved predictive accuracies of
around 70 percent
um you know bearing in mind that that 50
of the instances were satisfiable and 50
were unsatisfiable so random guessing
would get you 50 percent
and uh we were getting 70 you know i
don't
recommend you throw out your sat solver
and use this model instead
but uh and by the way i should also
stress to you
this model doesn't give you a
certificate of satisfiability it just
gives you a gas
uh which is 70 accurate but uh
i think it says something about the
learnability of uh
of this class of problems nonetheless
and i think it
offers some interesting kind of grist
for theoretical insight
so here's what the model did it said
um first of all let me um let me look at
one feature
to do and i'll say more actually in the
next
slide about what these features were um
well actually maybe i'll go into the
features in a second let me just say
what's on this slide so
um let me stress to you we trained this
model only on 100 variable problems and
then we evaluated it on problems going
all the way up
and to 600 variables and we saw no
evidence that accuracy fell with size
in fact if anything accuracy seemed to
improve very slightly with size
um and uh
we and let me show you here what the
features were so
uh by the way i i see in zoom um
evidence that something is happening in
the chat
i can't see the chat while i'm sharing
my slides i'm very happy to be
interrupted by questions so
if anyone has anything that would be fun
for us to talk about
um maybe even let me pause now and see
if anyone wants to interject
actually uh i i do have a question yeah
please go ahead um
and it has to do with the the features
that you used in this predictive model
uh you did so you said you didn't use
probing features probing
features just to remind us is are
features that
uh are about the run of the solver right
so
is that fair and yeah so probing
features are you know
take some solver and run it for a
bounded amount of time
okay and here these were all
quote unquote like structural features
just formula features if you will right
sure and could you tell us what those
features were and how many of them did
you use
to construct your model so you're
looking at the model
the model is this decision tree it is a
two node decision tree in two features
and this slide exactly defines what
those features are
okay so so the model says let me compute
the
coefficient of variation of the lp slack
vector which i'll define in a second
if it's bigger than you know four
thousandths
then return sat otherwise
look at the um the this part
this feature that has to do with the
ratio of positive to negative
um occurrences of variables and
if that's a little bit unbalanced then
return status
again and otherwise return on set um
that's that's the entire model
and it's able to give you 70 predictions
yeah isn't that crazy
yeah now i did you try to apply this to
kind of structured classes of instances
as well or only to random
yeah we we have looked at some
structured classes of instances
it's difficult to find structured
classes of instances that are exactly
50 50 saturn sat so that tends to make
the prediction problem easier
um so one reason why this is a nice kind
of test set for us to look at is that
uh it it kind of is is about as hard as
possible to
to sort of cheat at um but uh
but yeah we haven't found that this this
sort of phenomenon is uh
is restricted to uniformland and three
set
i'm assuming subsequently you're going
to talk a little bit about satzilla as
well where you considered a much larger
set of features
to to where you're using it for
algorithm selection but
um there you're predicting runtime as
opposed to satisfying
i'm not actually for the rest of this
talk um
i'm not going to speak at all about uh
runtime pretty
rent and prediction again but i guess
i'll say and
that this this two node decision tree
was based on this set of
maybe almost 100 features kind of from
this space um having thrown out the
uh the probing features so it isn't that
i only gave it those two to look at
and those are the two that it picked out
of a much larger set and
indeed this is the set that we use for
setzln for for
a smack and some other things as well
thank you
um sorry so let me go ahead to uh to
this result
um so you know so
this first feat so we're only using two
features but let me say the features are
a little computationally powerful right
so
the first feature is based on solving a
linear programming relaxation of the sat
problem which
takes sort of roughly cubic time so you
solve this lp relaxation
and then you look at the the variables
in the lp relaxation
and you ask how close they are to being
integral and so you make a variable
a vector for each of these variables
saying how close it is to integral
and then you look at the coefficient of
variation in that vector
so although that's only one feature it's
kind of doing a lot of work
um so um so so that's kind of
interesting right this is telling us
that the the amount of variation
in the slackness of this lp is telling
us quite a lot about whether uniform
random threesat is
is going to turn out to be sad or not um
and in those cases where there isn't
very much variation you know conditional
on that variation being low
um then then we look at this ratio of
positive to negative
occurrences of variables we look at the
mean ratio
and and when that mean ratio skews uh
skews high
then again we we tend to think that the
the instance is sat and otherwise we
tend to think it's unsuck
when you look at these numbers um that
are both kind of a little bit bigger
than zero what do they mean
it's important for you to say that these
features are normalized to have mean
zero and standard deviation one on the
training set
so um so we're saying that they're
bigger than
average right zero would be average um
and this is a big i don't want to lose
this detail this is a big part of why
our models were able to generalize so we
when we evaluate on instances of a new
size
this normalization would presumably
change on a new size so here's how we do
that without cheating i have a model
that was
trained only on 100 variable instances
and then you give me
like a 700 variable instance that i've
never seen before
i don't know what the normalization is
to get back to mean zero and standard
deviation one
so what i do is i generate many many
instances of that size which i can do
because it's uniform random three set i
can generate anything i like
um i use i don't solve those instances
i just generate them and i use them to
sample um
and i compute the features on them uh
which i can do because the features are
cheap to compute
and i use those to estimate the
normalization factors and then on my one
test
instance i use those normalization
factors that i got from the many
instances that i generated and threw
away
and they use those factors to compute
the features for the test instance
and then i make a prediction from the
test instance so i don't solve anything
at the larger size but i do compute
features from anything so that i can
normalize them
so so that's an important detail about
how we're able to generalize
okay so so now let me tell you about
work from
much more recently from last year so
as the question just indicated
everything that we were doing so far
depended on these features that we had
to kind of make up based on insight
about sat so
i had to know that the lp relaxation of
sad was a thing and that it might be
useful for something
and you know it's kind of crazy most
people don't think the lp really
relaxation of sad is any good so what if
i didn't have it you know then i would
have come up with something completely
different you know what if
something else is also really good and i
didn't have that
how would i ever know well you know
these days
um the whole kind of learning landscape
has changed from using features to
end and learning using deep learning and
has really transformed
the state of the art in a lot of
different uh ml applications
so we became intrigued by thinking about
whether
we could predict satisfiability status
and
taking raw problem representations as
inputs
um you know just as as has been possible
in other domains
and this is joint work with
my students cameron shannon hartford
um and chris cameron the lead author on
this is uh
also a visitor in this simon semester so
i encourage you to reach out to him
uh if you have if you're interested in
this work
so um let me just say
you know and and learning you know
people talk about it being kind of
totally end to end
but let's take an example uh you know
there's a little bit of a fly in that
ointment so let's think about
computer vision how that worked in
computer vision you know it used to be
that feature engineering was the name of
the game
um david lowe who used to be in my
department
made his career on having come up with a
set of features
back around the turn of the millennium
for machine
and vision he he got like 80 000
citations for these sift features
which now you know a day on a gpu with a
neural network will produce you
something like the sift features
so now features just get identified
automatically with these deep
architectures
but the catches you need to give them
the right structural assumptions or
inductive biases in the machine learning
and it turned out that in vision the
right inductive bias was convolutions
which corresponds to uh translation
invariants
so you know the picture of the puppy is
the same picture of a puppy no matter
where you slide it around in the vision
in the kind of viewport um
you know that that dramatically lowered
the number of parameters that you needed
to learn and made
um deep learning for vision practical so
what would be the right structural
property for us to
impose on a sat formula
uh represented in conjunctive normal
form well
convolution would not be appropriate for
sat because there isn't a notion of
locality right convolution says
you know when you're looking for a
picture of a puppy you only have to look
at the
pixels that are all close together and
when you slide them around it's the same
picture
um well with a sat formula you can sort
of garble it all around and get the same
side formula so locality is not not the
important thing
so in sat the key insight is that the
formula is unchanged
by renaming variables or reordering
clauses
because the and and or operations in cnf
are commutative
so we want to say that the input to a
subformula should be represented as an
exchangeable matrix
so what happens if i try to use a
standard feed forward layer of a neural
network
on an exchangeable matrix like this well
typically what what you would most
naively do in
machine learning is you take your
exchangeable matrix and you'd vectorize
it
then you define your feed forward layer
as
some non-linear activation function
sigma applied to
a weight matrix um multiplied by
this uh vectorized input x and uh
you know the the dimensions of this
thing would be um n times m
and by k where k is whatever um
number of neurons in the next layer that
i want to feed forward to
notice that this is going to treat every
permutation as being different because
i've got
different weights everywhere in this
matrix and this is going to violate the
invariance property that we want
so something that you might want to do
if you wanted to enforce invariance a
way you might think about enforcing a
variance
would be to tie parameters in this
matrix w
so that they're all the same under every
permutation in order to enforce this
permutation and variance
so um what would happen if you do this
well
if your input is a set it turns out that
you only get to have
two free parameters per channel which is
to say per output neuron that you would
um
you would achieve this result was
achieved by
a couple of different papers but uh most
uh
thoroughly by manzil at all's a deep
sets paper
uh in follow-up work to to that work
and with uh some co-authors um
notably my student jason hartford
devin graham and c mcgravenbosch
we showed that if x is an exchangeable
matrix
um then you only get to have four free
parameters per channel
that correspond to one parameter for the
same element
one parameter for the for all elements
in the same row
one parameter for all elements in the
same column and one parameter for
everything else
now this um this forced us to
represent this weight matrix explicitly
and then to do a matrix multiplication
uh which is expensive for the the feed
forward pass in the network
and thus makes training the network
really expensive
but it can be efficiently implemented by
uh
you making some commutative pooling
operations
uh and this causes the runtime to scale
linearly with the number of non-zeros in
the input matrix
rather than um requiring this matrix
multiplication so um
we can say um compute a
um one pool across
every row i i keep doing vertical rows
for some reason
one pull across every row one pool
across every column and one pool across
all elements in the matrix
and uh notice that uh
when we're not representing w explicitly
and we're just speaking about pooling
across rose column
oh yeah please go ahead uh this may be a
good time to maybe go back
a slide because i really want to
understand what you're saying here yeah
sure
i understood the problem that you
mentioned which is
the actually can you go back one more
slide yeah
uh all right yeah right so here
everyone else can probably see who it is
but i i don't see it oh sorry
it's me vijay oh hey vj thanks that's
what i thought
okay so the the issue here is
you know you vectorize the input formula
right and then you uh you're doing this
uh multiplication with this matrix here
but the problem is that it violates the
permutation in variance that's
associated with boolean formulas
so in order to fix that problem you tie
the parameters in w to enforce what do
you mean by that
type of parameters so so what i mean is
um so so i want my w instead
to to look like the w on the right um
so so this kind of crazy uh
quilt structure here uh is a way of
saying i only want to have
um four possible parameter values
so uh i don't know can you see my mouse
moving around yeah
yeah so so never mind this this last
column here is x
right so so this the rest of this thing
is w
and there's only four colors in w here
so what i'm trying to say is
w is only really allowed to have four
distinct numbers in it which are defined
by these four colors
and then i'm going to take these these
four numbers and build them out into a w
that's structured like this
so one one parameter is going to be on
the diagonal
and that's going to so um it was
important here that i said
consider the case of k equals n times m
so i'm trying to build
a next layer that's the same size as as
my
my input so i've got a square matrix
there um
so so so i i've got one one element here
that's the diagonal so that's saying
uh for every element i'm going to give
back the thing that i got
um and so permutation means
um i that's gonna have to be the same
everywhere so that if i if i permute
something
no matter where it is i'm always going
to give back the same thing that i got
and and that's sort of the easiest one
to see but
i'm similarly um everything in the same
row
everything in the same column you know
it's got to behave the same way under
under permutations so
so if you if you think about you know
what happens
if you sort of start with an
unconstrained matrix and sort of play
the game
as i permute rows and columns i don't
want anything to change in the output
when i do a permutation
what does that mean about what has to
get tied um you know you end up with a
picture that looks like this
and these are the only degrees of
freedom that you're allowed to have if
you want the same thing to happen under
every permutation
um and uh
and and then this is just a way of
saying you know given that i really only
have these four parameters and then
building out this w implicitly
um surely i don't really need to build
out this this actual matrix and do a
matrix multiplication that was all based
on four numbers
you know surely there's some implicit
way that i can get the same answer out
um and you know indeed we can by just
kind of taking sums and distorting these
numbers based on sums
and the last point that i was wanting to
make which is important so let me return
to it
is is now i actually don't really have
dependence on the size of the input
right notice with the the feed forward
thing
you know i really meant i actually had
this explicit w matrix that was
um n by m right so it really cared about
the number of
clauses and variables my whole model was
trained based on a particular number of
clauses and variables
but now i've only got four parameters
four is a constant it doesn't depend on
n or m
so once i have this implicit
representation you can actually give it
a sub formula of a different size than
it was ever trained on and you can
evaluate the model on it
notice that the standard feed forward
architecture just kind of barf on that
it doesn't even understand
what that means it doesn't have the
right number of parameters to evaluate
something with a different input size
but as a kind of side effect of having
enforced permutation equal variance
um we we get the ability to evaluate in
different size inputs for free
it doesn't mean it would necessarily do
something sensible but it uh
it doesn't break if you give it
something of a different size
um and this icml paper
um with uh jason um
devin and cmac um culminated in a
theorem that said
that this is sort of maximally
expressive if what you want is
permutation equivariance so
you can't satisfy permutation equal
variance with more than four free
parameters
so this is kind of an argument that
these exchangeable matrix layers amount
to a kind of convolution for
exchangeable matrices it's the the most
expressive feed-forward layer that you
can have that that respects these equal
variances
um let me note that since we did this
work um
graph convolution networks gcns have
become popular
and they're just really kind of a
different route up the same mountain
they
they're also um as expressive as what
i've just defined if this is your
favorite
family of models go for it and use them
um
you know we built on the thing that we
um we previously did but
we haven't seen any particular reason
why one is better than the other
and that builds from the fact that um
the um the variable clause graph the
bipartite variable clause graph is a
equivalent representation to this matrix
that
that i've been talking about so
um so now i'm talking about um this work
uh
with cameron nadal uh from triple ai
here's the architecture that we use to
do um satisfiability status prediction
at the phase transition
so uh so previously i talked about a
model
that had two features right two
parameters those
those weights that i showed you and got
seventy
70
accuracy now here's what you would do if
you didn't care about how many
parameters you possibly had
but you want to go end to end so
here we we have this architecture with
these exchangeable matrix layers
we have 128 channels each which means uh
we we do those exchangeable
um you know four parameters per channel
um models um 128 times
and then we stack those eight deep so
that gives us
4096 parameters and we set our
activation function to leaky
value which is like value rectified
linear units
but where you have a slight downward
slope instead of a constant zero
never mind if you don't know what that
means um we
we pull over rows and columns and then
to flatten out into this
pool problem representation one real
value per channel
and then we build a decoder on this kind
of embedding
that is a standard feed forward network
of um
32 neurons per hidden layer and
eventually
pop out at a single real value between
zero and one which is our prediction of
satisfiability status
and we trained it using binary cross
entropy loss
so long story short you know we did this
we inconvenienced a lot of electrons on
a gpu for a really long
time training this on a gigantic number
of sad instances
again looking only at 100 variable
problems
and then we evaluated them on larger
problems again between
150 and 600 variable problems
and and here's the accuracy that we got
um so we see that here even though we
didn't benefit from having these
features which is a really tremendous
benefit
um we were able to uh to get accuracies
um
more uh you know nearing eighty percent
uh and actually you know coming
uh up to eighty one percent on the 600
variable problems although maybe that's
a bit of an outlier
and which took hours to solve using this
exchangeable architecture
and uh just for comparison here's how
those handcrafted features did um and
this this is using all handcrafted
features not just the two headcrafted
features so that's it's a little bit
bigger than you saw before
but i'm using any handcrafted features
were
on average seven percent worse than
these exchangeable models
and so now here's another we may have to
wrap up in a couple
no problem i'm actually almost done here
i have only one slide after this
um um
this dotted line here is saying um
what if i was to train and test on
problems of the same size
so you see that if you wanted to target
particular sizes you do better than you
if you have to generalize across sizes
but it doesn't
dramatically change the story and
here's the last thing i want to say um
if you uh the the other benefit of these
exchangeable models
is that they're dramatically cheaper to
evaluate
so the uh recall that our
um our handcrafted features required
cubic time they required solving linear
programs on every input and
and that scales um you know badly as
as problems get bigger and bigger these
exchangeable networks
um you know you saw how they work
they're just kind of linear algebra
running forward it's all um linear time
so
um they basically didn't take they're
really cheap and they didn't take
appreciably longer time as we got got
bigger and bigger
so this could matter in some
applications to be able to build models
that are
dramatically cheaper to evaluate at
runtime
although i don't want to sweep it under
the rug they're also dramatically more
expensive to train offline
so they took kind of days rather than
minutes to train offline
so um let me leave it there so i've
showed that it's possible to use machine
learning to predict satisfiability
status of unseen sad instances
considerably better than random guessing
on uniform random threesat
we're able to build models on tiny sag
instances and generalize them well to
much larger instances
in particular we showed that we could
train on 100 variable problems and some
little loss of accuracy on 600 variable
problems
when we trained using hand tuned
features we can examine
our models to gain theoretical insight
and we were able to build a very
accurate model that needed only two
features
and we're able to build even more
accurate models without
any domain knowledge at all using
end-to-end learning and the secret sauce
was
these exchangeable matrix layers which i
think might be an enabling technology
for
other sat work to come so thanks for
your attention
thank you kevin for a fantastic job
thank you so much
uh in interest of time you just have one
question have you applied
and was asked by victor miller have you
applied this to
industrial problems um yeah i think
we've tried it a bit um
again we've uh we've been a bit worried
that
that some of these problems are really
lopsided um
the the other real catch um is
the gpu methods that we're using are
really limited by the size
the the sorry the end-to-end methods
have to run on a gpu they're really
limited by the size of gpu memory
so we we definitely don't need to use
uniform random three set problems but we
do need to use
smallish problems whose um no
you know rep sparse matrix
representations not the full matrix but
the
the sparse matrix with the non-zeros can
fit on on a gpu
so we're starting to see gpus with
larger memories but but that has been a
practical limitation for us
and you know we've been doing some kind
of engineering around that with sort of
iterative implementations that don't
need to put the entire thing on a gpu
and do sampling
i think that just makes the whole
implementation more painful so
and this is definitely not something you
want to use on your circuit verification
problems today
thank you again for a fantastic talk let
me clap for everybody here
and uh yes and thanks for everybody's
patience uh
due to the delay in starting the session
thank you again bye bye
thanks kevin cool thanks everybody i
guess we'll uh i'll pop over to gather
and see if anyone wants to chat
afterwards